and you know once once you start beating
all your demons at one night you're
actually you know like the lord of the
demons that kids they call move out for
the reason they call them blue god for
the blue boy like now I'm the demon
posit feel it's like an old wash lights
movie the teacher used to beat you up
every day and now you're the one beating
up the teacher the student has surpassed
the master you know except for it's more
like several different rivalries I guess
okay this might be a bunch I think yeah
we're about to see a very cool matchup
that one I've seen all day today as a
solo male player as much that I wish
that someone was uh that there was his
ass on top eight there's gotta be a yeah
that question this is also punch like
anyway the guys are getting ready
once again this is losers finals so it
is a first two three raced 3 and said
and we are packed so every match from
now on is 3 out of 5 and then whomever
faces blue got a grand finals has to
beat blue got twice I look high I love
high use doing the DJ I need one year
cook I think he's just checking this out
maybe it wasn't good last time he go
link you know with the legal hits we can
make sure it has the pusher that's the
most important part good front without
that that is so satisfying when you're
the one level hitting somebody it's like
oh I got your ass it's almost like my
writer when you don't have to the honk
don't hassle the hoff you total of Japan
up against the Lakers USA it's a scary
one the scary one for sure I believe was
this the matchup that was round one of
the water imitational actually hold on I
don't even know hey man see now I'm now
I'm curious well I loved the intensity
in to set up it's like hey know what the
screens got to be exactly in the right
place burner measure shouts Tokita
I must be exactly 12 inches to play
optimally well I you know he's a he's a
dentist right so he probably knows like
my medical like reasons and stuff oh he
just does things what's the medical
reason for him doing demon rage in front
of the projector medical reason is
feeling like a god feel good to perform
good right all right Darrell that was
immediate I imagine from you toda we're
gonna see an immediate well it'll be as
well to be honest with you he has a
pocket as well now it's not gonna happen
not this first game I don't think but it
is three out of five so we're there is
totally a possibility of character
switches from pool players that's right
I don't know that is that type of
matchup yet we'll find out after Game
one I think he most definitely
and again like we talked about the as
well is very very warm right like as
well as Ben has very not to excuse me
the the Carol is very for link Lake
Skelton speak to an amazing you total
what's doing great upland telling you
ran it's a new guy I mean the same for
allusions link or is right that back n
both of these players only loss to move
on blue God is there is there a team in
right now so they've got to get back to
me looking got to find each other for
its back turn mix-up is kind of working
right now he's getting the pressure but
what's bailing amazing into the 666 beat
tech Crouch under it
incredible you told us got the pressure
going right now and then below that
entire round was just a masterclass that
was incredible I'll if I stayed in one
place I said okay I know that you'll
come hear me
again we seek this small stage by the
way yeah so I mean this is probably the
most volatile stage in Soul Calibur
right because it is the smallest and it
also has no walls at all
Jordan follow that might have like it's
not enough Irving out hitting the tech
traps he's setting him up
you can't overextend here because of
that switch oh what a CIO GI trying to
catch him rolling oh my god you can use
auto could definitely come back by the
nervous chair one piece you totaled huge
Peter advantage good blot saw the look
of it whip punishment pokes oh you
totally another loan goes for the to a
right there he recognizes that make
horse have been challenging another time
where he did well that was the forward
throw even a whip on it yeah again
you're talking about the stepping on the
sixth beauty it's very fact superlinear
and the first plan if you will get so
much time in truck as well the rare soul
charge from you Toto blow error than a
birth of a sea turtles sixty be poor PB
follow-up so let's there from link oars
to to one right now in round two get
there's a lot of are from your photo but
will
Oh watch out they just might blows oh
come on I'm Stefan and everything that's
one of the strong parts about putting
somebody at the ledge it's not that
you're always trying to wring them out
it's you're trying to make them scared
of the Lincoln predict they're moving a
little better yeah what the class made
the 60 B couple that was cooling it on
deck as well he's got to start watching
out your total goes to the right he's
got a lot of hard work with Whitman
alway punished yeah he's gonna see
you're not happening okay well I guess
he keeps his bar lean course is about to
get a bar for that you got to work with
on the side of your todo right now so go
two or three six B B's if you need some
water step Matt just ready to see that
which step like that buzz phrase under
break attack GI on the preak and string
that stuff oh it's just barely on it to
you Toto take it the first game very
very close beautiful
I mean that was really close though is
the thing like gee me I don't know if
Ling short link or should let that face
him in any way shape or form sometime it
just kind of happens you get rung up
that's one of the stages where that just
got is a stage where sometimes you get
rung I had died and also it's three out
of five right so you got a little bit of
room to work with to adjust to adapt
link is as a person that I've known to
adjust and adapt to stage right there
pushing them closer to the wall remember
the wall is is a big factor in this
stage yes it will take a certain amount
of hits before is broken but it will
still let you extend your will
accomplish like any other wall okay whoa
wake up nice block and then ending up
getting the 6e to spite the fact that he
was in without words man this hands I
guess it hits low enough
good block man I got it I gotta say it's
almost those fortunate for a link that
no one is trying to GI the second in
Ashley because it actually is quite
front oh cool I can't I do think it's
because you've been making a living
yes sure can get on this side big damage
right there get the mix up as well now
more chance for link the blocks and he
packs off while it's alive so that was
crazy
you Toto want to run in rounds again
fight this one seems like it's gonna go
down to the wire
solos definitely not even so very fun
always yeah well actually they happen
both of them have been stepping a ton
you know you know stuff won't I got
right there see you'll stop in front of
each other guard then step almost every
single exchange has been
Wow you tried that with punishment at
all
very nice mike foale to the brown
I think 6bb is gonna be the clapping
link ours at this point it's like a
blessing and a curse you have to do that
as your because it's one of your best
ways to confirm it it's a creek starter
but it's it's pretty committal bar to
work with right now and you may end up
having to use as much of it as possible
honestly total first part look at real
confident right now
you're horizontals right different link
that was a good snap because he knows
you told has been stopping and stepping
every single time like we talked about
people he's on deck there's the mix on
though that's gonna knock down that's
poor boy does not work and now he's it
alone Oh guaranteed actually baby I'm
not too sure somebody's gonna have to
crack three home but early throw good
luck
that's a lot of damage early for length
Wow you example just brave one date but
although I was a recite I've gotta watch
oh you try too hard you're the sole
charge but I can remember you Toto has
hardly ever used as meters like it's
exactly but it's right when leakers
could least expect it right and when he
uses the so try he's only using it as a
burst he's not really doing it on the
sole charge specific I guess a lot of
the time you're looking for the 6b
before it is so what he was not just
looking for it but when you're in sole
charge you know you can do the spells
multiple times would easily write up so
that makes doing what is it for a plus B
as you input it makes it good as a
hooter just to us out there well rather
than trying to good for a really worked
out incredibly right there for link ORS
it's gonna be one to one right now and
again three out of five right so it's
gonna be a lot more of these adaptations
we're gonna see a stage switch as well
you Toto I guess he didn't really like
that too much probably wants the more
volatile type stages right the one with
more ring out these easy ones like the
easy way to just back throw you and then
bring you out or something like
Oh rare to see that happen unfortunately
doesn't get a whole lot of it all back
throw no tech from you Toto remember
Waldo can't attack off the back throws
like this right he can also block walk
back turn Kathy said you Stockton ready
to break in time boy you won't take the
big boy back flow damage that's might
slow you total recognizing that trying
to get his advantage back right now he's
fighting on the back foot but he's doing
a great job of poking out and instead of
close enough no barber again I'd like
the choice right he wanted to put him in
the check situation that's what the
armor tenet scared you told home made
him allowed him to get in there are
moments where you can still attack that
booth but you have to really choose the
right spot you guessed wrong and
favorites the course on twitch duck for
gentlemen she was looking for something
else
whoa whoa again almost the big punish
unfortunate fits right there for you
Toto of course is gonna make the light
poles even now yeah not hearing that
right now you see that that beat-up boat
Stonewall I mean you know he's got he's
got he's at the stage the manager said
did he get the silver sword it looks
like it broke the armor though it truly
is good to see he's still trying to get
away nice break on the throw
armor okay yeah I hope the folks with
delay strings are really important right
because it makes them think oh I'm not
gonna actually do it but then you tell
me when you're starting it up and they
press a button they kick on her head and
now look at what it's affording recourse
man again I must point out that you
total is Rudy nice break he's so passive
with meter there were a good amount of
opportunities here when he couldn't use
the saw charge to create space between
him and link and instead and kind of
just so the match is over yeah that's
one of the first things I noticed back
in the world Invitational capacity is
with bar it I I feel like he would have
the perfect package of a player if he
started using his bar a little bit less
soldier bold oh right like other photos
you almost think that they want so
charged just so they can use their city
so charge three things like this right
he's even if it's not soul charged for
the sake of meeting like mix ups or
strings like that right that it's like
what you were talking about earlier
either creating space or getting out of
a precarious situation because remember
so trudge does get you out as long as
they like serve water it hits a real one
it's invincible it pushes away sometimes
they're trying to do like to jump attack
to go over your lure you knock them down
you get okie instead anyway important
mechanic that you total does not value
as much as some of the other players
that we see the top eight I think you
totals thinking about it I think we can
get stalling to please don't go as well
it'll do it I think that if he wants to
show a new face now is the time
now I know it's a pig okay
character select he might be going as
well so I remember a little while back
you Toto was interviewed and one of the
things he said he is he thinking he
feels as if he has maybe four or five
characters that are at tournament level
ready okay right however we've only ever
seen the the as well and the vol dog oh
man this would be an interesting big
Japan things wrapped might be the
postcard in the game right now so if he
did talk about how he has several
Twitter already characters if you were
to pick Rafael that may be a terrifying
sight yeah he's talking about he's
really that he's just unsure he my man's
my man's do not play with my heart like
this please I love SAS Laval too much
for this whoa no way no way go away
Wow hold on he's not locked in yet
if he's gonna lowly mash me and go back
to the boat dock door oh that's my man
that's my man spooky all right so he has
us level this this should be interesting
one thing that will really change about
dying about this matchup is that Sasebo
has a really good super - when you
actually kind of similar to the yard
when O'Carroll it's a really good way to
you turn the tide and to first
impression of the opponent SAS lamelle
works on a lot of anyo they pick 1550s
up like a six a mixup and three a right
so you're going to a you're gonna see a
ton of terrains one of the best
interrupt moves that this character has
just gonna build up those marks of
course they get the nice time stop
column yeah curses not only given time
saw combos but they also allow extra
suffer that does so much one of the best
replenishes that makers of the video
very smart from you Toto you can tell
he's done his homework
nice block this time three a be linked
very smartly watching out for the
situation easy sick that is easy debt
that's one of the basic wall combos for
this character because it gives you two
creases and a grip of damage alright so
starting over as far as marks go but you
total looking great
[Music]
the water throws are loud and it's all
momentum right now for you Toto I love
the use of one a right here from you
total six AP he gets a curse off back
yep and then the mix-up okay
nice block there from complaint course
it's got a watch out for a lot again
he's gonna catch it soon not the barks
we'll see about that if he gets the
chance you tried two four six beat the
block makes running out of meter he's
gonna beat that if you wants to far to
curses is really easy to combo Appa for
most of his first cancel of yeah -
curses is kind of like bread and butter
status on three curses is when the
damage starts even is when you get the
combo video cut the [ __ ] are three K
but link was looking for it back he was
looking for another read yeah but no
ties comp onto a fake be journaling that
might break the walls breakthroughs he
tried to ring out from it but instead he
gets a throw weight will that's has the
best refers to read out in black period
so you meet those soul charge here is
scary yeah and you can see that you see
me standing out of six a range so he
doesn't get reversed back yeah yeah talk
through anything
I'll beat at the pie though so SAS
labelled when he throws you at the ledge
it is a 50-50 because both of his
boroughs ring you out yes back through
will ring you out and command throw
forward will ring you out yo SAS
horizontal sour Ricky on can't ride it
like duck or step away that's why he was
outside of six a range for a little
silly big garden like okay I don't
really want to get like you guys ring
out but let's not feel very good the
second he stood into his ranges when
things kind of went sour right there
we're finally gonna see the sick freak
come out versus is a sliver oh man so in
my personal opinion uh three patch when
Siegfried was computer to be one of the
best cards in the game without question
I fall exam melted very very well in the
matchup during dark legacy right in
disease I know also a top tier on that
time so you stopped here at all times in
this game to recruit you're kidding
anyway we haven't seen at the critical
edge of Zosima becoming faster just yet
however I'm sure that that's got to be
dawning out links mine right now because
that super is really scary especially
when you're already behind
early life isn't you're just trying to
come back so the changes to the scene on
this might be three months pretty just
lease is so much death it's cheap when
they have no soul to soul meter alright
not a full Barb's overview all right my
turn for some pressure stats which it ha
and don't whip it's the full damage off
vide try to use it are we you know
punished either really unfortunate but
link course is gonna take this in the
bank you need every opportunity right
now he's trying no no no so again that's
one of us a lot of strong super yeah we
damaged by the grip I is he trying to
get towards uh the second Dark Legacy
actually I wonder if that's why he did
it not just the damage
there's one right now okay ace hold
[Music]
survive that rock my goodness that's one
of the strengths of Siegfried once he
gets him to dark legacy he has every
comeback factor available oh you tried
to suck it pretty much just ice it up
yeah my turn to to get that crotch mix
up in there
I love the spacing game right now from
the course he's like recognizing me if
it needs to be completely a cheater
range where he needs to be directly
inside Salamanca because those are those
bass hold fixes to make it harder for
utilities as horizontals exactly real oh
I thought a mechanic first have you got
a mark right now so close was he
fighting his nails just out the nurse it
could be no possible card break
situation go for you toto
let's see if playing so basic right now
that's a good firm mix time you Toto's a
red card bar might be a factor
definitely starting to look like an AGA
comes out he's really trying to lay on
the pressure think the wall is gonna hit
yeah okay just frame big damage he's
gonna slow trench put all that up
oh it's bad dark legacies outsold
charges also out this is one of his last
couple of wit courses got a plumbing
stops as we hit the final round
right now USA versus Japan negative up
block in total two meters that see he's
still looming that's the only strong
when he has been the crisis now be able
to the change
couple of lethal impatient anime even on
damage oh my god it's so even mix up
while the second part hit top the 46 be
right now Lee courses for secret social
Joker no he's got to make something
happen right now he's oh my incredible 5
a to punish he's gonna so charge out
here now is incredible huge modems
he said that he possibly has four to
five other characters at tournament
level and we're seeing exactly that he
wants Southeast Asian majors off of as
well could we see him possibly win this
tournament office axel amel that was
amazing so Lake horse would get